a vista de pájaro coronado por algunos
de los picos más altos del planeta se
encuentra el hotel hard rock zone del
valle de junta una región remota del
norte a pakistán sus espectaculares
paisajes naturales cautivaron escritor
james hilton para crear su particular
paraíso perdido el shangri-la en 1933 un
siglo después este joven empresario
paquistaní ha querido recrear la utopía
de hilton a 3000 metros de altura
estamos intentando promover algo nuevo
en todo el mundo que son los hoteles de
lujo de gran altitud ha sido todo un
desafío construir este hotel todo lo
hemos tenido que traer de abajo
transportándolo en caminatas que tenían
que subir 3000 metros por una
zigzagueante y estrecha carretera
este resort de cinco estrellas nos
muestra una imagen desconocida a
pakistán un país golpeado por el
extremismo desayuno tradicional de
bretaña productos orgánicos agua de
glaciar un atardecer en el sky bar ante
las restricciones de la pandemia muchos
paquistaníes han encontrado aquí una
válvula de escape de la ciudad
hemos tardado 17 horas en coche para
venir aquí y nos ha valido la pena
todo el mundo debería venir a ver la
belleza de la naturaleza de este rincón
de pakistán tan desconocido
cada día las atracciones de turismo de
aventura se llenan de jóvenes familias
como la de en rama que vienen de todos
los rincones para disfrutar y hacerse
selfish y miradores de película puentes
colgantes paseos en pony junto al río o
panorámicas en los glaciares
las colosales montañas nevadas que
soportan el techo del mundo son testigos
de centenares de paquistaníes que vienen
a diario a este mirador de 360 grados al
que ya has visita como un peregrino de
puerto
tenemos mucho potencial para el turismo
de montaña pero debido a las
restricciones del cobi 19 ahora vienen
pocos turistas internacionales a hacer
escalada sin embargo el turismo nacional
ha crecido mucho en estos últimos años
el desarrollo mejorado el nivel de vida
de los aldeanos pero un turismo sin
control masificado podría hipotecar el
futuro de este valle milenario toneladas
de basura acumulada a las puertas de los
hoteles el calentamiento del suelo o la
evolución de los vehículos están dejando
una huella ambiental irreversible
resulta paradójico que el boom del
turismo local en la región haya llegado
de la mano de una catástrofe natural
este impresionante lago de 21 kilómetros
de longitud y 100 metros de profundidad
es el resultado de una avalancha masiva
que provocó el desbordamiento del río
junto a negando las localidades vecinas
en 2010 las poblaciones quedaron
aisladas por 5 años hasta que ingenieros
chinos construyeron túneles para
facilitar el acceso
ahora el lago del desastre es una
atracción que visita miles de familias
para dar paseos en barca o practicar el
de textil
de todos los sitios que hemos visitado
en la uat abad es el lugar que más me
gusta el color turquesa de las aguas las
vistas increíbles que tiene con las
montañas nevadas pero bajo las aguas
azuladas por las que navega esta
embarcación turística está sumergido el
que era el pueblo que dio nombre a la
uat abad y safar testigo al atrás y
ahora reconvertido en barquero es un
afectado el desastre
y
perdí todas mis tierras en una mujer y
cuatro hijos es muy triste lo que
ocurrió
pero el lago me a algún trabajo con el
que puedo alimentar a mi familia y ver
hay más de mil glaciares como este
bendice en el valle sus aguas son fuente
de vida y alimento para las comunidades
que lo habitan pero el calentamiento
global está acelerando el derretimiento
del hielo de los glaciares que cuando se
resquebraja tiene consecuencias nefastas
en las poblaciones
una hilera de esqueletos de ladrillos
abandonados es el único vestigio que
queda en este lugar que albergó el
mercado alimentos más plantea de guelmim
al que venía a comprar zaira el torrente
de hielo y lodo ya negó todo dejando la
tierra agrietada y polvorienta como en
el desierto
es un aviso de la naturaleza de los
efectos del cambio climático no debemos
ignorar la
de
esta tierra la heredamos de nuestros
abuelos y si queremos dejarla en
herencia a nuestros hijos tenemos que
luchar por un turismo sostenible
zaira ha puesto su granito de arena con
una cota el restaurante que dirige con
su marido temen corts y sport for people
futsal for six so you can make it
eider jafar fault a pesar de ser un
negocio modesto está teniendo mucha
clientela por lo que ha decidido ampliar
la habitaciones utilizando técnicas
tradicionales materiales naturales y
ecológicos tiene un pequeño huerto en el
que cultivan hortalizas y frutas
orgánicas con las que zaira preparan sus
recetas que ofertan el menú diario a los
huéspedes
tristán yo
este fondo saque del centro nuestra
economía local y se basa en el turismo
los ingresos del turismo han traído
prosperidad de esta región de gilgit
baltistán rebosar y turistas se ha
invertido en educación en carreteras
pero también en construir grandes
hoteles de cemento que tienen un impacto
negativo para el medio ambiente y
amenazan nuestro futuro chupa chups
effects vía y seria
los quejidos de los glaciares su
deshielo nos advierten de como la
sobreexplotación turística
pone en peligro el mito de shangrilá y
nos recuerdan que si no se apuesta por
la sostenibilidad puede desaparecer la
herencia milenaria de este valle